let's see if we can add five and
two-fifths
two three and four-fifths pause this
video and see if you can figure out what
this is
all right now let's do this together
we've had a little bit of practice
adding mixed numbers in the past and so
one way to think about it is you could
view five and two-fifths as five plus
two-fifths
and then we're to that we're going to be
adding three and four-fifths which you
could view as three plus four fifths
and then you could just change the order
with which you are adding and say all
right well i could say five plus three
so that's five plus three and then to
that i could add two-fifths and
four-fifths so plus
two-fifths
plus four-fifths and what is that going
to get me well five plus three is going
to be equal to eight
eight plus and then if i have two-fifths
and i add four more fifths to that well
now i'm going to have six-fifths
two of something plus four of that
something's gonna be six of that
something and the something in this case
are fifths so now i'm going to have
six-fifths
so some of you might be tempted to say
hey isn't this just going to be equal to
eight
and
six-fifths
and you wouldn't be completely wrong if
you said that but pause this video and
think about why this feels a little bit
off
well the reason why this isn't standard
is the fractional part of this mixed
number six-fifths is greater than one so
there's a hole inside of this six-fifths
so the standard way to do this is see if
we can break out that whole and what do
i mean by that well i could rewrite
eight plus six-fifths as
eight plus
six-fifths is the same thing as a whole
or five-fifths
plus one-fifth
and why is this useful
well five-fifths is the same thing as
one
and so now i can say this is going to be
equal to eight plus one whole is nine
that's eight plus the fifths and then
what i have left over is one-fifth so
nine and one-fifth and so this is the
direction that people will traditionally
go in now there's another way that you
could approach it which is really the
same idea we're just writing things a
little bit differently we could write
this as
five
and
two-fifths
plus
plus
three
and four-fifths and notice the way that
i wrote it i put all the fractions in
the fraction column i guess you could
call it that way and i put all of our
whole numbers underneath each other and
if i had multiple digits here i would
align them according to place value
and then what we could do is we say okay
two-fifths plus four-fifths is going to
be six-fifths
we could write six-fifths there we say
hey there's something a little bit fishy
about six-fifths that's really the same
thing as five-fifths plus one-fifth or
you could say that's the same thing as
one and one-fifth six-fifths is equal to
one and one-fifth and so what you could
do is you could write the one-fifth part
in the fractions column and then the one
well now you're going to be regrouping
that into our whole numbers so you put a
one right over there notice two-fifths
plus four-fifths is
one and one-fifth which is the same
thing as six-fifths and then you add the
whole number of parts one plus five plus
three is 9. so you get 9 and one-fifths
but hopefully you realize that these are
really the same idea just different way
of writing things